[Aplausos]
qué pasa si les dijera que no somos
libres antes de responderme les voy a
contar una historia ingreso en una
tienda de deportes y me detengo a ver el
último modelo de raqueta de rafa nadal
por si alguien no lo conoce es uno de
los mejores tenistas del mundo
mis ojos van hacia arriba hacia abajo
hacia un costado y hacia el otro
observando también el nuevo conjunto de
jordi y remera en seguida me imagino
ejecutando los mismos golpes que el
bueno mentira me imagino jugando nada
más
en ese instante me emociono aumenta mis
pulsaciones y no puedo evitar sonreír
antes ideas una sonrisa que rápidamente
se me va cuando veo el precio de la
raqueta y uso cabizbajo totalmente
derrotado en un instante me pareció ver
que una microcámara seguía mis
movimientos pero me dije a mí mismo
seguro se trata de un nuevo sistema
antirrobo y me olvidé el asunto
cronológicamente en paralelo es tu
historia y como si fuese un detrás de
escenas
múltiples cámaras seguían cada uno de
mis movimientos la cámara de la entrada
realizó un reconocimiento facial para
identificarme utilizando los datos
comprados a una conocida red social
accedieron a todas mis preferencias de
consumo sabía mi edad composición
familiar música favorita deportes que
práctico quiénes eran mis contactos y
andy a saber qué otros datos decidieron
que poner mi canción favorita mejoraría
mi experiencia de consumo el sistema de
iluminación inteligente resalto la
sección de tenis lo cual me atrajo
rápidamente hacia ese sector un joven
vendedor con el que casualmente
compartíamos la pasión por el tenis
rápidamente se acercó asesorarme
mientras tanto las cámaras de la
estantería reconocí a mi exultante
estado de ánimo tomar mis expresiones
faciales los cambios en mis pulsaciones
y grababan mi conversación con el
vendedor también captaban mi decepción
al conocer el precio
y luego me voy a salir del local toda
esta información quedaba registrada en
una base de datos como consumidor' 137
federico armentano a los pocos días me
llega por correo electrónico una oferta
con la raqueta de rafa nadal
pese al descuento no disponía del dinero
con lo cual no pude hacer la compra una
semana más tarde navegando por internet
se me aparece la raqueta de mis sueños a
un precio excepcional a pagar en 12
cuotas y sin intereses pensé este es el
destino es una señal para que lo compre
no puedo dejar pasar esta oportunidad
con lo cual hice la compra soy un poco
inocente a veces del otro lado el
sistema de inteligencia artificial
cómputo 11 que el lenguaje binario
indicó un éxito en la venta también
registra lo indispensable de la
financiación para que yo me convierta en
comprador apoyándose también en el
acceso a los resúmenes electrónicos de
mi tarjetas de crédito como si esto
fuera poco utilizando la información de
otros consumidores que compraron la
misma raqueta decide enviarme ofertas de
productos relacionados todas a pagar en
amplias cuotas pero esta vez con una
amigable tasa de interés
dos semanas más tarde poniéndome al día
con mis redes sociales recibo la super
oferta de zapatillas medias short remera
y muñequeras de regalos la verdad no
estaba en mis planes comprar todo eso
pero el pago por mes es tan bajo que
decidió hacerlo y ahora puedo salir a la
cancha como un campeón
les parece exagerado esta historia les
parece que es ficción créanme que no lo
es
existen todas las tecnologías que les
estoy comentando solo que en esta
historia yo las uni aunque la verdad no
sé si falta tanto para que esto suceda
entonces yo les pregunto piensan que
somos libres para responder que esto lo
primero sería saber qué es la libertad
de acuerdo a la real academia española
la libertad de elección consiste en
formar la propia voluntad y adoptar una
resolución sin que existe interferencia
ni presión de terceros alguien cree que
esto ocurre en la historia que vivimos
consideran que son libres al comprar al
elegir gobernantes en cualquier aspecto
de nuestras vidas
hoy voy a hablarles de una era que nos
atraviesa una era que es capaz de unir a
familias a miles de kilómetros de
distancia e incluso salvar vidas como
así también puede atentar contra una de
las condiciones que creíamos intocables
nuestra libertad
esta era se denomina big data y algunos
autores la resumen por la regla de las
tres vez la primera vez volumen la
información generada en los últimos años
es mayor que la que se generó en toda la
historia de la humanidad variedad antes
teníamos datos estructurados en filas y
columnas hoy tenemos datos no
estructurados en imágenes documentos de
texto grabaciones
y por si esto fuera poco tenemos
y si por cierto fuera poco tenemos una
cantidad de datos enormes para analizar
pero
no sólo es malo todo lo que está pasando
con el big data también por otra parte
tenemos el big data relacionado a
la medicina a la informática a la
economía
y
le voy a contar un ejemplo de un caso
concreto el big data ayudando en salud
en un estudio de pacientes que
contrajeron infecciones hospitalarias
nos piden averiguar cuáles son las
principales causas que más muertes están
produciendo tenemos una base con más de
300.000 filas y más de cinco alumnas
estos son más de 30 millones de datos si
hacemos mal el análisis no se tomarán
las medidas necesarias si demoramos se
perderán vidas hasta que encontremos
esas causas depuramos una base
monstruosa trabajando día y noche
estimamos datos faltantes y solucionamos
inconsistencias nos aseguramos que los
datos que usamos se ajustan a los
modelos teóricos que vamos a aplicar
luego mediante modelos de probabilidad
vemos cómo aumenta o disminuye la
probabilidad de muerte al agregar o
eliminar variables al modelo
finalmente emitimos un informe a los
médicos a cargo quienes con esa
evidencia logran que se tomen tres
medidas a nivel nacional que ayudan a
reducir un 20%
muertes por infecciones hospitalarias al
año ese 20% significa salvar miles de
vidas al año
entonces ya no hablamos de un excel con
30 millones de datos hablamos de
familias a las que cambiamos su vida
podríamos ir un poco más y decir que
podríamos ayudar a salvar el mundo
encontramos el big date en torno a
ciudades inteligentes donde distintos
factores como el transporte la
contaminación la energía sustentable y
la salud están conectados entre sí
pensemos en una ciudad como funes o
rosario donde además de medidores de
velocidad tengamos medidores de
contaminación que nos permitan ver todo
el tiempo la cantidad de dióxido de
carbono que hay en el aire que estamos
respirando suena bueno entonces el vista
te es bueno o malo veamos un ejemplo
donde depende de quien lo use y cómo se
use con un amigo desarrollamos hace unos
años una herramienta que entre otras
funciones se utilizaba para la selección
de deportistas competitivos les cuento
brevemente se cargan distintos datos del
jugador y el sistema nos dice las
probabilidades que tiene de convertirse
en un deportista profesional imaginemos
ahora un hijo sobrino hermana alguien a
quien queramos mucho en una prueba de
jugadores de fútbol
llamémosle danny
con ilusión dan y limpio sus botines la
noche anterior y se presenta a la mañana
siguiente a la prueba el sistema carga
sus datos peso altura velocidad en
tramos cortos y largos capacidad de
salto y excluye fríamente a danny del
proceso les parece justo de esto el
sistema no tiene en cuenta el esfuerzo
la superación la fortaleza mental
incluso no deja de ser una herramienta
creada por personas la cual no está
libre de errores aquí el big data
prescinde del factor humano lo reemplaza
nos gusta un mundo en el que una máquina
nos diga si somos buenos o malos para
cierta tarea bueno veamos qué ocurre hoy
en día sin el big data danny se presenta
en la prueba y esta vez es evaluado con
las metodologías que se utilizan
habitualmente forma equipo con 11
desconocidos y enfrentan al al equipo
titular del cuadro con el que soñó jugar
toda su vida su posición preferida la
delantera transcurridos 45 minutos la
prueba resultó una tortura
sus compañeros de equipo en realidad son
sus competidores en esa prueba y sus
rivales son un equipo aceitado por años
de trabajo pierden 5 a 0 y su
participación fue nula un exfutbolista
observador de la prueba no logra captar
parte de ese talento de danny quien
queda fuera la primera oportunidad y
esto les parece justo de hecho la
historia nos marca cientos de ejemplos
de errores en la detección de figuras
internacionales hasta acá vemos que para
el mismo caso el mal uso del big data
puede ser tan injusto como el no uso del
mismo y si el sistema pudiera captar
parte de ese talento y si pudiera
decirle al seleccionador cuidado oigan y
no tuvo un buen día pero su velocidad es
un 30% mayor a la media su capacidad de
salto y potencia se asemejan a los de un
deportista de élite puede que el sistema
se equivoque pero con estas estadísticas
no valdría la pena darle una segunda
oportunidad de adán y aquí el big tata
se utiliza como complemento del ojo
humano busca dar segundas oportunidades
en lugar de reemplazar
pero entonces el big data es nuestro
enemigo o aliado al igual que la ciencia
el big data no es bueno ni malo depende
de la ética y de la responsabilidad de
quienes lo utilizamos
pensemos que es como un golem para
quienes no saben un golem es una
criatura antropomórfica hecha de barro
su creador posee sobre él un control
total y este nos va a obedecer siempre
sin importar las consecuencias
podemos pedirle que nos haga unos
masajes que limpie la mesa o también
podemos pedirle que haga daño o que
lastima a las personas al igual que el
golem el vic tt es una herramienta muy
poderosa pero sin intencionalidad propia
como usuarios de las herramientas que
nos acerca esta era debemos informarnos
y luchar por nuestro derecho a la
libertad
recuerden que podemos
desde hacer nuestra vida más placentera
hacer daño o cambiar el mundo para bien
solo está en nosotros qué decisión vamos
a tomar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]